les tunisiens se sont réveillés ce matin
au son de nouvelles annonces politiques
le gel du parlement est prolongé
jusqu'en décembre 2022 date de nouvelles
élections législatives et en juillet
prochain place à un référendum pour
voter sur les réformes
constitutionnelles
les annonces faites hier soir par le
président kaïs saïd lors d'un discours à
la nation
plus de précision avec notre
correspondant est une se passionne
chebbi comme à son habitude de présent
la république tunisienne qui a essayé de
prend la parole de manière assez
surprenante et surprises d'après ce
n'est pas au courant de ses prises de
paroles monde est pris au dépourvu le
présent d'art public qui devait
s'exprimer le 17 décembre prochain selon
des rumeurs il allait a annoncé la
dissolution du parlement ou encore
heureux remodelé ou alors refaire une
nouvelle constitution il est revenu sur
certains aspects de la vie quotidienne
en tunisie total lutte contre la
corruption qui continue par rapport aux
différents partis politiques la raison
pour laquelle il a décidé de prolonger
le gel du parlement
premièrement le parlement reste
suspendue gelé jusqu'à la date de
l'organisation de nouvelles élections
et deuxièmement l'organisation de
consultations populaires à partir de
début janvier
certains préparatifs ont déjà commencé
pour les plateformes électroniques et
pour les questions qui seront posées qui
seront claires et courtes
réforme constitutionnelle et d'autres
projets seront soumis à un référendum le
25 juillet date de la commémoration de
la déclaration de la réclame
donc pas de dissolution du parlement
pour le mandat de la république et
simplement le prolongement du gel en
attendant des élections législatives
prévues en décembre 2022